[موسيقى]
هنا ال8:00 بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
ليبارد الالمانيه بعيده المنال جونس يتحفظ
على حسم الجبل حول تدريب بها وباريس قلقه
من انتقام الروسي
كيف غلاوس من الشمال
بعد خيبه املها في الحصول على الدبابات
اوكرانيا تعزز جيشها وتحول مدينه اشباح
لقاعده تدريب مكثف
ايران توسع حمله التهديداتها ضد اوروبا
قوائم ارهاب المماثله واستهدف مصالح في
اسيا وخطه عاجله للرد
في غرفه المعيشه التخزين والمكتب لعنه
الوثائق السريه تلاحق بيض ومداهمه وشيكا
لمنزله الثاني
[موسيقى]
وسعيده مؤقتا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
كانت اوكرانيا ربما على بعد خطوه واحده من
تغيير مسار الحرب كليا لصالحها لكن تشعر
ان هناك من خذلها فكل الضغوط الدوليه
لم تنجح في اقناع المانيا بالموافقه على
ارسال الدباباتها الحاسمه في هذا الوقت
الحساسي من الحرب الرفض الالماني وضع كيف
في مواجهه ضعيفه نوعا ما امام روسيا وترك
واشنطن وحلفاء اوكرانيا امام خيارات
محدوده سيما وان اكياس بامثل حاجه في
الوقت الراهن لهذا الدعم بعد تدمير وتعطل
دباباتها منذ بدايه الحرب في الوقت الذي
تستعد فيه روسيا لهجوم واسع وشيكا لكن
لماذا ترفض المانيا ارسال الدباباتها
لاوكرانيا في البدايه ابنه برلين
الجيش الالماني من هذه الدبابات ليس كبيرا
كما اشترطت برلين ان ترسل امريكا اولا
دبابات لكيف مقابل ارسال دبا وهو منفاه
لاحقا وزير الدفاع الالماني وبرر التردد
الالماني بالقلق من تبعات ارسال الدبابات
وما قد ينجم عن تصاعدي وتره الحرب يعني
يمكن ان نقول ان المانيا تخشى رد فعل
موسكو او تحسب حساب اي انتقام روسي خصوصا
وان روسيا تعلم جيدا ما قد تحدثه هذه
الدبابات من فرق على ارض المعركه فما الذي
يميزها فعليا نتابع خصائص الدبابه
الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
والمانيا لم تقفل الباب نهائيا بشان مساله
ارسال الدبابات لاوكرانيا وقالت انها لم
تقرر بعد ولكنها رفضت تحديد قطر زمنيه
لقراره البيان الفرنسيه والالمانيه بعد
لقاء الرئيس مانويل ماكرون والمستشر اشترط
فيه الرئيس الفرنسي بان ارسال الدبابات
الاوكرانيا يجب ان لا يعرض امن بلاده
للخطر بدوره قال المتشر الالماني
2 ان الامر يتم بالتشور مع الحلفاء وتعاهد
بمواصله الدعم عموما
الطريقه التي سلكناها في الماضي ومناقشه
الاوضاع عن كثب ما اصدقائنا وحلفاءنا هي
التي سنمضي بها في المستقبل نخشى ان تستمر
هذه الحرب لفتره طويله ولهذا من المهم
بنسبه الى اوكرانيا ان تعلم اننا لن
نتوادى في دعمنا وسنواصل العمل طالما كان
ذلك ضروريا وهو ما فعلناه خلال الفتره
الماضيه ولا يزال الامر مهما للمستقبل
نعمل من خلال تنسيق الوثيق بيننا
فيما يتعلق بمدرعه لوكلاخ طلبت من وزير
الدفاع الاشتغال على الموضوع لا شيء
مستبعد والتقييم سيتم بشكل جماعي
وبالاستناد على ثلاثه معايير اولا وكما
فعل النموذج البدايه ان لا يتم الامر بغرض
تصعيده وقد التزمنا بهذه النقطه المعيار
الثاني هو ان نستطيع تقديم مساعده حقيقيه
وفعاله لاصدقائنا الاوكرانيين وثا اخذوا
التطورات الميدانيه بعاني الاعتبار فضلا
عن مده التدريب التي يتطلبها استخدام
المدرعه
حسين قنيبر من باريس حسين اهلا بك معنا
كما استمعنا الرئيس قبل قليل قال لا شيئا
مستبعد عندما سئل عن امكانيه ارسال
الدبابات الكلير الفرنسيه الى اوكرانيا
كذلك ماذا قيل ايضا في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
بينس وايمان والمكان
المستشار الالماني تهرب من السؤال بل اجاب
عنه بشكل موارد وغير واضح لنا حيث
نيه المانيا ارسال الدبابات اليوبارد 2
الى
اوكرانيا اما الرئيس الفرنسي فبلاضافه الى
المقطع الصوتي الذي بث وهو قال حرفيا كي
تكون الامور او واضحه وغير ملتبسه صهيب
حرفيا قال نحن ندرس هذا الموضوع طلبته من
وزير الدفاع العمل على هذا الموضوع
وسندرسه بشكل جماعي وسطى ثلاثه معايير
طلبته مراعاتها اولا الا تكون الخطوه
تصعيديه في حال قررنا ارسال هذه الدبابات
الى اوكرانيا والمقصود هنا الا تكون هذه
الدبابات التي تستخدم في حال ارسالها
لغايات هجوميه بل دفاعيه فقط هذا نهجه من
اعتمدناه قال ماكرون في محاوله لعدم اثاره
الجانب الروسي والثانيه يجب ان تقدم هذه
بعد في حاله ارسالها دعما حقيقيا وفاعلا
لاصدقائنا الاوكرانيين يجب ان تكون هناك
مهل زمنيه لتدريبهم على استخدامها واخيرا
وصهيب قال الرئيس الفرنسي يجب ان ندرس هذا
الموضوع بشكل جماعي وان لا يؤثر ذلك على
قدراتنا الدفاعيه المقصود هنا عدم تاثير
ارسال الدبابات على المخزون الاستراتيجي
لفرنسا من هذه الدبابات ومن الاسلحه
الثقيله
التي تناولها هذا اللقاء بين الرئيس
الفرنسي والمستشار الالماني وكذلك اللافت
في البيان الختامي هل همم الدولتان
الاوروبيتان الكبيرهتان المانيا وفرنسا
باتا على او بيتفاعل وفاق الان
فقط من حيث الشكل واللهجه المعتمده لكن في
العمق تبكي الخلافات تبقى قائمه على اكثر
من خط اولا المانيا كانت اعلنت انها ستخصص
200 مليار يورو لمساعده مواطنيها على
مواجهه ارتفاع اسعار الغاز بعد قرار روسيا
وقف ضخ الغاز الروسي الى اوروبا هذا
اعتبارته فرنسا خروجا على خطه اوروبيه
شامله وتغريبه من المصالح الوطنيه
الالمانيه ايضا ما قالته المانيا سابقا عن
تخصيص مبلغ 100 مليار يورو لتشكيل لجيش هو
الاكثر تجهيزا في اوروبا اعتباراته فرنسا
خروجا على ما يدعو اليه مكروه من استقلال
استراتيجي عسكري اوروبي ضمن خطه جماعيه
وما جاء في البيان الختام حول هذه النقاط
يعني يعكس همم توافق ظاهري على تجاوز
الخلافات ولكن في العمق تبقى الخلافات
قائمه في كل الاحوال جاء في البيان
الختامي ان هذه الدول المصممه على تعزيز
دفاع المشترك وعلى تعزيز الجناح الاوروبي
ضمن الحلف الاطلسي وتعزيز
الروابط بين الاتحاد الاوروبي والحلف
الاطلسي انه دينه باكثر العبارات حزما جاء
في البيان المشترك العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا التي سنواصل اظهار دعمنا لها في
جميع المجالات الممكنه خصوصا السياسيه
والعسكريه والاقتصاديه والماليه
والانسانيه والاجتماعيه والثقافيه وسنواصل
مكافحه الافلات من العقاب بالنسبه
للمسؤولين عن جرائم الحرب ومساعدات
اوكرانيا قضائيا هذا بعض من ما جاء في
البيان المشترك الفرنسي الالماني الصادر
مساء اليوم بعد هذا اليوم الالماني
الفرنسي الطويل في باريس تحديدا في قصر
وقبله في جامعه السوربون صباحا عندما كان
هناك الجانب الاحتفال من الذكرى السنويه
الستين لتوقيع معاهده التعاون بين البلدين
صهيب حسين قنيبر من باريس شكرا جزيلا
مواصلات الدعم الغربيه ويبقى المانيا
بابها مفتوحا لارسال الدبابات دفع روسيا
للاستمرار في لجنه التحديد في اخر
التحذيرات الروسيه اكد رئيسه مجلس الدومه
الروسي فيلودن ان امداد الغربي لاوكرانيا
باسلحه الهجوميه لشد ضربات على الاراضي
الروسيه يهدد بكارثه عالميه واحذر من رد
الروسي الموجع معتبرا ان الدعم الغربي
العسكري لكيف تحريض الاستفزازي يؤجز
السرعه
من جانبه اتهم دي متر من البداف نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن في الاتحاد الروسيه اتهم
الغربه في روسيا او تدميرها نحذرا من
امكانيه تحالف عسكري جديد في العالم
ان تخصيص اسلحه ثقيله الاوكرانيا لا يدعوا
مجال للشك في ان اعداء روسيا سيحاولون
ارهاقها او ربما تدميرها ولديهم ما يكفي
من الاسلحه واذا لازمه الامر
سيصنعون اسلحه جديده
معي من ابو ظبي الان عبر خدمه زوم
الدبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه سيد بدياني اهلا
بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه كيف
يمكن فهم هذا الموقف الالماني من عدم
ارسال الدبابات الالمانيه اليوبارتو
خلال الاجتماع
فقط
اقرب وقت
هذا سؤال التالي سيد همم
الرئيس الفرنسي اليوم كذلك في لقائه مع
المستشار الالماني كما تبعنا قبل قليل مع
مراسلنا همم شولد قال ان المانيا تعمل
بالتنسيق مع الحلفاء همم وان همم يعني
التنسيق ما يزال مستمرا هل يعني هذا انه
الباب ما زال مفتوحا يعني المانيا
الخلفاء ممكن ان يغير رايهم ويرسلوا هذه
الدبابات اقصد حتى الدبابات الامريكيه
وكذلك الالمانيه
بكل تاكيد كما قلت نحن على ثقه تامه من ان
سيتم قرار بخصوص ارسال هذه الدبابات الى
اوكرانيا في اسرع وقت ممكن ولهذا السبب قد
بدات تدريبات الجنود اللبنانيين الاستخدام
همم على استخدام هذه الدبابات
في بولندا حسب ما قال وزير الدفاع الجراني
من هذه الخلافات الاوروبيه الا يمكن ان
همم الحلفاء لا يريدون تزويكم تزويد
الاوكرانيين باسلحه يمكن ان تستفز روسيا
لكي تشن ربما عمليات انتقاميه او هو ما
حذرت منه روسيا كذلك هل همم الاوروبيون
وخاصه المانيا متخوفه من انتقام روسي
تعتقد لذلك هي متردده
طبعا لان يعني جميع القرارات
يتخذ الوقت
نحن بنحتاج الى الوقت المناسب والوقت
الكافي لان ارسال الدبابات ليس يعني امر
سهلا لانه استخدام التطبيقات يعني طبعا
تحتاج الى تدريبات
والصيانه وكل هذه الاشياء المتعلقه
باستخدام الدبابات
والتدريب الجيش الاوكراني همم اسمح لي
ساعود اليك نتابع هذا الملف حول ملف
التدريب اذا حيث يبدو انك خيبه الامل
الاوكرانيه مشاهدينا بالحصول على دبابات
متطوره ده دفعها للبحث عن حل الاخر فعاله
التشكيله وحدات عسكريه جديده مدربه على
اسلحه حلف الناتو يدمجها في قوات الجيش
فيما نقلت شبكه عن مسؤولين العسكريين
اوكرانيين قولهم ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تواصل التدريب بالقرب من الح البيلاروسيه
استعدادا لربيع دموي
هذه المنطقه قرب الحدود البيلاروسيا
واسمها مدينه ليبيات والتي تعرف بمدينه
الاشباح حولتها كيف خلال الايام الاخيره
الى قاعده تدريب لقواتها المدينه التي تقع
شماليه البلاد هجرها سكانها بعد كارثه
تشيرنوبل حيث كانت المدينه مهيئه انا ذات
للمفاعل النووي واليوم تستغل اوكرانيا
تضاريسها المتنوعه لتدريب القوات عن
مختلفه الظروف
ان المدينه استفاده من وضعها صناع المسلسل
الشهير شنو نوبل لتصوير حلقات من المسلسل
هناك كما قام فريقه عمل لعبه كول اوف
ديوتي فور بتصوير المدينه في هذه اللعبه
[موسيقى]
في مواجهه ذلك كشفت واشنطن منذ ايام
تدريباتها للقوات الاوكرانيه على انواع
المختلفه من الاسلحه وكان قائد واركان
المشتركه الامريكيه تحدث عن ان البرنامج
التدريبي للقوات الاوكرانيه سيكون اكثر
توسعا وتعقيدا وسيتواصل لفتره تتراوح بين
خمسه وثمانيه اسابيع ونعود الى ضيفه
هل هذا المعسكر الذي اقامته الاوكرانيا في
مدينه افريقيا
هل هو ااه الخطه اذا كان حلفاؤها قد
خذلوها لم يرسلوا اليها الدبابات التي
تطلبها
لا هذا يعني عمل
يعني نحن يعني نقوم بهذا العمل في يعني
بشكل متزامن مع التصويت اوكرانيا هذه
المساعدات الاجنبيه لان العراق من ان
روسيا خسرت اكثر من 300 دبابه و 6200 مركز
واليوم تشعر نقص شديدا لهذه المعدات
وروسيا لم تتخلى عن قطط احتلال اوكرانيا
وانها تكون يعني كما قلت بحاجه قواتها
عشان هجمات جديده في الاشهر المقبله وربما
من شمال وان يجب علينا ان لن نحروس يا اي
فرصه لمواصله عدوان العسكري يعني
هذا المعسكر الذي اقامته اوكرانيا الان
الغايه منه ماذا التحضير فعلا ل- همم ربيع
دموي لمعركه كبيره قادمه في شهر مارس الى
ابريل ابريل القادم
نعم هو تحضير لصد الهجوم المحتمل من جانب
الروسيا لان كما قلت لم تتخلى روسيا عن
فكره احتلال وتدمير اوكرانيا ونحن لازم
نسوي كل شيء ممكن عشان تدريب قوات
المحتلين من ارضنا وبالنسبه الاوكرانيا
للمساعدات العسكريه ليست نزوى او يعني
لكنها كما قلت حاجه مليحه
نفس الوقت خلال جميع المساعدات الممكنه
وخاصه الاسلحه الثقيله مثل الدبابات
والمدفعيه ونحن كمان نتوقع ان سيكون
اجتماع رامز التاسع همم اجتماعا تزويد
اوكراني اليسا
يعني همم يعني همم افضل همم من من غياتنا
او او او او احداث مقنحن نسعى الى كمان
تضبيط شكرا بالطائرات ليس فقط الدبابات
سنرى اذا همم ما الذي سيتوصل له الحلفاء
اذا في اجتماع رمشتاين القادم شكرا جزيلا
لك في طالب ودياننا انتم مدموسي الاخرين
كنتم معنا مباشره من ابو ظبي عبر خدمه زوم
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اقاله درعي اول
اختبار لنتن ياهو والهزه الاولى في سلسله
تصدع حكومه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد نتابع من ايران حيث وسع
النظام الايراني حمله التهديد ضد اوروبا
حيث حذر من الرد بالمثل على تصويت
البرلمان الاوروبي لادراج الحرس الثوري
على القائمه السوداء للمنظمات الارهابيه
والدعوه لفرض عقوبه عليه وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه حسين امير عبد الله قال ان
البرلمان الاوروبيه يطلق النار على نفسه
بوضعه الحرس الثوري على هذه القائمه وقال
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه اذا لم يتحرك
الاوروبيون بعقلانيه فان اي رد المحتمل من
جانب ايران وارد من جهتها هددت
الاستخبارات الايرانيه اوروبا باستهداف
مصالحها باسيا بعد الحديث
المرحله الاولى من تصنيف الحرس الثوري
منظمه الارهاب
بالامس عقدنا اجتماع الاستثنائيا لمده
ساعات في لجنه الامن القومي وادى الى بيان
سيصدره البرلمان في حال ذهب قرار البرلمان
الاوروبي الى مجلس الوزراء وتمت الموافقه
عليه وسنوافق على خطتنا العاجله في
البرلمان لمواجهه القرار وقد وضع قوه
عسكريه موجوده في دستورنا على قائمه
الارهاب ونحن بدورنا سنضع جميع القوات
الاوروبيه الموجوده في الخليج واجزاء اخرى
من العالم على القائمه هذا الاجراء يزيد
من الفجوه بيننا وبين الدول الموجوده على
طاوله المفاوضات وهو من بين الالاعيب التي
تقوم بها الدول الاوروبيه الثلاث وخاصه
امريكا لتاخير خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
[موسيقى]
فوريه
من شانه وضع الحرس الثوري الايراني في
قائمه الارهاب او قوائم العقوبات وسنعترف
بالجيوش الاوروبيه في المنطقه كم مجموعات
ومنظمات ارهابيه وسنتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه
لمواجهتها
وتابع من لندن معنا عارف نصر وهو الباحث
في الشان الايراني استاذ عارف اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه كذلك قائد الحرس
الثوري الايراني
قال ان على الاوروبيين تحمل عواقب في حال
اخطائه برايك الى اين يمكن ان تصل ايران
في انتقامها او ردها على الاوروبيين في
حال ادرجوا الحرس الثوري والبسيج على
قوائم الارهاب
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهدين العربيه الكرام
الواقع بان براي بان هذه التصريحات من
الحرس الثوري ما هي الا همم كلام فارغ ولا
يمكن ان نتصور تحرك من قبل همم
فيما يتعلق بهذه التهديدات وذلك لان بربما
تهديدات مشابهه الى القوات الامريكيه
عندما صنف في الحرس الثوري كمنظم ارهابيه
ايضا راينا وعيد من هذا النوع لكن ما لم
يتحرك الحرس الثوري خاصه ونحن نتحدث الان
عن 27 دوله هي من كبريات الدول في العالم
علاقات اقتصاديه والملف انه ايضا مرتبط
بها من هنا يمكن قراءه هذه التهديدات هي
محاوله من حراس الثوري اللي ثنيان الجانب
الاوروبي من الماضي
كيف تتوقع رده فعل الاوروبيين اذا يعني
هذه التصريحات او هذه التهديدات هل يمكن
ان تثنيهم هذه في حاله الايرانيه عن اتخاذ
القرار بتصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه
في ما يبدو بان هنالك عده اراه موجوده
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي على الاقل ما
شاهدناها اليوم من خلال ما صرح به عبد
الله هيام بانه كان بتواصل مع جوزيف دورين
وهذا طالب بانه اكد له جزر بريل بان همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يزال لم يتخذ غرار
تصنيف الحرس الثوري همم كمنظمه ارهابيه من
هنا فيما يبدو بان لا يزال مغاربه الجانب
الاوروبي تعتمد على همم عقوبات عن الافراد
وكذلك المؤسسات الفرعيه التابعه للحراسه
الثوره ولم تتخذ قرارها
ارجو ان تبقى معي ساعود اليك في زاويه
ايرانيه اخرى مشاهدينا تهديدات ايران
لاوروبا باستهداف في المصالح وايقاف العمل
باتفاقيات وغيرها تتزام كذلك مع مروري
اربعه اشهر على احد اكبر الازمات الداخليه
التي شهدتها البلاد في السنوات الاخيره
الاحتجاجات و ثلاثيه بدات على اثري مقتل
الشابه مساء اميني تبيعها الكثير من
القضايا التي اثارت الراي العامه العالميه
من اعدام المحتاجين والتعذيب الى مصير
مجهول ينتظر العلم
قصه الفتاه الايرانيه ماشا امين التي
اشعلت شراره اطول موجه احتجاجه بدات بعد
اعتقالها على يد شرطه الاخلاق ووفاتها في
ال 16 من سبتمبر الماضي
150 مدينه ايرانيه حسب المعارضه على مدار
لاسباب الصحيه
يؤكدونا تعرضها لضربه على الراس
التظاهرات جميلات بعنف
او الى ديسمبر الماضي لاحتواء الاحتجاجات
صدر قرار بحل الشرطه الاخلاق
مصيرا ممثله
في لندن اربعه اشهر منذ اندلاع الاحتجاجات
بعد مقتل مهسا امينه اين ترى الاحتجاجات
اليوم
باتت بالمرحله الايجابيه يعني العمل
خرج من مرحله الحراك الثوريه الذي هدفه
ارهاق النظام الهدفه يعني ايه الضغط على
النظام الايراني لتنفيذ بعض المصالح لكنما
لم يكن همم هنالك هاجسي القياده للمرحله
الانتقاليه لكن فيما يبدوا الان لدى
المعارضه بالخارج وحتى طلبات من الداخل عن
ان ينتقل الحراك الثوري من المرحله
السلبيه الى المرحله الايجابيه التي
تتوج من خلال ايجاد قياده مشتركه الى
مرحله ما بعد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه فيما
يبدو عن الصعيد الداخلي ايضا هنالك نقطه
مهمه وهي ان هذا الحراك الثوري ادى الى
ايجاد همم تشققات وخلافات ايه داخليه داخل
النظام الايراني والبعض يتحدث الان ان عدد
من وزراء همم
ماذا عن الاصوات التي تتحدث عن همم تراجع
زخم هذه الاحتجاجات في ايران الان
يعني انا اعتقد بان لم يتراجع زخم
الاحتجاجات وانما نحن طوال الشهور الاربعه
الماضيه راينا تغيير بالتكات عامل الطقس
نحن نعلم الان هنالك موجه صقيع بارد بارده
في المناطق الوسطى من ايران وكذلك العامل
الاقتصادي ولا ننسى بان قطع الانترنت
والنقطه الرابعه وهي القمع والاعدامات ادت
الى ان تتغير التكتكات من هنا يجب قراءه
اا تراجع همم زخم الاحتجاجات الشارع على
انها تغير تكتيك وليس همم تغليل من زخم
همم الاحتجاج في ايران عارف النصر من لندن
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
طلبت عائله رهينه البلجيكيه المعتقل في
ايران الحكومه البلجيكيه ببذلي ما في
وسعها للافراج عن اوليدي بنك
العربيه ان شقيقه
اداره السجن بمغادرتها لمده ربع ساعه في
اليوم فقط الى ان العائله اي قناه ان
الاحكام القاسيه التي اصدرتها محكمه
ايرانيه بحقه دليل على انعدام
لا يزالوا معتقلا في زنزانه انفراديه طرا
عليه بعض التحسن يتناول وجبتين عاديتين في
الاسبوع حصل على بعض المكملات الغذائيه
بعد ان تدهورت صحته هو معزول في زنزانه
يغادرها ربع ساعه في اليوم لتجول في ساحه
صغيره
[موسيقى]
موظفي البيت الابيض خلفا لرونت لاين وذلك
بعد الانباء التي تحدثت عن استقاله مرتقبه
لكبير موظفين البيت الابيض
وكانت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه اشارت الى
ان الاستقاله المرتقبه لكبير الموظفين في
البيت الابيض تتزامنه مع التحقيق بقضيه
وثائق بيضاء السريه
رئيس لجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب جيمس
كومار طالبه في وقت سابق بالكشف عن سجل
الزوار من وقت تنصيبه ومنحه مهله حتى
الثلاثين من يناير الرجال
وبالحديث اذا عن الوثائق السريه لبيض كشفت
مصادر العربيه قبل قليل ان مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الاف بي اي يدرس مداهمه منزل
بايظنا الثالث وذلك بعد يوم على اكتشاف
وزاره العدل المزيد من الوثائق اثناء
تفتيش منزل الرئيس في والمايكتون بولايه
لعنه الوثائق السريه لا تزالت لاحقا
الرئيس الامريكي
ست وثائقه جديده عثر عليها هذه المره في
منزل البيت البحث استمر قرابه اثني عشر
ساعه وجميله كل اماكن العمل والمعيشه
والتخزين في المنزل لحظه غياب بيض وزوجته
اثناء التفتيش الوثائق الست تعود لفتره
عضويته في مجلس الشيوخ واخرى اثناء توليه
منصب نائب الرئيس
الى وثائق اخرى عثر عليها في مقر اقامه
بعيد في الثانيه عشر من الشعر الجاري
ووثائق اخرى عثر عليها في مكتبه السابق في
مركز ابحاث بوشنطن
وثيقه اخرى تضع الديمقراطيين في موقف لا
يحسدون عليه بعد ان وجهه كثيرا من
الانتقادات الى الرئيس السابق الجمهوري
دونالد ترامب الذي يخضع هو الاخر لتحقيق
قضائي الاحتفاضه باكثر من مئه وثيقه سريه
على الرغم من مغادره واشنطن عام 2021 اما
الرئيس سيقف امام اسئله ملحه تدور حول تلك
الوثائق فحواها ومدى خطورتها عصام عبد
السلام العربيه
معنا من واشنطن دكتور
السياسيه دكتور اهلا بك معنا في اخبار
الساعه اكتشفت وثائق جديده في منزل
حديث الانبياء الان عن امكانيه تفتيش
منزليه الثاني كيف ترى موقف جو بايدن في
هذه القضيه
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه يعني ما يبدو لي
انه مصداقيه الرئيس بعيدا تتعرض للاستنساخ
مستمر واطئ المستوى لحد الان الامر لم يصل
الى حد الفضيحه لكنه
حقيقه يقوض مصداقيه
بخصوص الاحتفاظ بالوثائق يعني في اثناء
الانتقاده للرئيس السابق ترامب
هنا المدافعون عن الرئيس
يعني هو متعاون مع وزاره العدل الامريكيه
همم يعني همم يعني تعاون مع المحققين مع
المفتشين اقصد ومحاموه يقومون بتسليم هذه
الوثائق هل يمكن ان يشفع له هذا يعني ان
يكون في موقف افضل من ترامب هنا
يعني الفارق جوهري لهذا السبب انه فعلا
تعاون عندما اكتشف
معاونه وجود هذه الوثائق ابلغ الاف بي اي
جاء ال اف بي اي وفتش
منزل الرئيس بعكس ترامب الذي اصدرت
الحكومه او وزاره العدل يعني طلبا
بالتفتيش اعتقد هذا هو الفرق الاساسي بين
الاثنين وهذا هو ما يستخدمه بشكل مستمر
ومناصره الرئيس
بالفعل مساله احتفاظه بهذه الوثائق في
اقامته
الان ما دام همم القضيه همم حصلت مع بايدن
واا بات في هذا الموقف المحرج كما تفضلت
هل يمكن ان تؤثر على ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه ان تكون عاملا فيصلا
عاملا حااسما في قرار همم الترشح بيض من
عدمه
لحد الان هذا الامر ليس واضح ان يهتمد
الامر على التحقيق الذي تجريه وزاره العدل
لكن انا بتصور ما دام ان الرئيس يظهر
تعاونه مع السلطات و اييي فانه يمكن ان
يتجاوز هذه المشكله
مصداقيته تعرضت للضرر بلا شك لكنه لم
يخالف لقانون
ولم يتصرف على على نحو يقوم على الاستهزاء
او الانتقام المؤسسات الدوله كما فعل
الرئيس السابق ترامب اعتقد لحد الان
الخلاف هو بين الحزب الجمهوري
والديمقراطيه بخصوص هذا الموضوع وليس
خلافا عاما بين الناس همم
بدانا نسمع اخبار عن احتمال استقاله كبير
وفي البيت الابيض رون كلاين همم الى اي حد
يعكس هذا ربما بدايه تصدع او هناك ازمه في
فريق بايرن بسبب قضيه الوثائق تعتقد يمكن
ربطوها كذلك بمساله الوثائق
لا لا لا اعتقد الامر مرتبط بقضيه الوثائق
المتعلقه باحمال يعني هذا امر واضح بين
المنتخب
الاستقاله مرتبطه باسباب اخرى وهذه تحدث
طيب
همم قضيه اهمال كما تفضل ما الذي يجعل
الرئيس يحتفظ بهذه الوثائق او ياخذها معه
للبيت او لمركز الابحاث وخاصه انها من
ايام ما كان نائبا للرئيس دكتور من وجهه
نظرك ما الذي يدفعه الى الاحتفاظ بهذا
الوثائق السريه
اعتقد سلوكه اظهر اهمالا واضحا اا بخصوص
الاحتفاظ بوثائق حكوميه الوثائق الاخيره
التي كشفت لحد الان لا نعرف اذا كانت
وثائق سريه ام لا الذي يضعف الرئيس
هنا هو
تصريحاته عندما اكتشفت الوثائق مع الرئيس
ترامب وقال ان السلوك رئيس ترامب غير
مسؤول كيف كله ان يحتفظ بالوثائق الى
اخرين اعتقد
انه ايضا قام بنفس الشيء يعني واخذ معه
الوثائق الى المنزل شكرا جزيلا لك همم
لمداخلتك معنا هذا مثلا الدكتور العقيل
عباس انتم الخبير في الشؤون السياسيه
العاصمه
[موسيقى]
بعد اربعه ايام من قرار المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه ترى رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
الى اقاله القائمه باعماله وزير الداخليه
رئيس حركه شاص الدينيه اقالته
هجم المحكمه العليا في كتاب الاقاله حيث
تعتبر قرارها انقلاب على قرار الناخب
الاسرائيلي في الانتخابات الاخيره في
مقاطع وزراء الصهيونيه الدينيه جلسه
الحكومه بسبب قيامها
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله زي الحلبي
مقعد درعي ليمين نتنياهو بقي فارغا مع
بدايه جلسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن درع
اعاده فوصل متاخرا وكانه يلمح الى ان
اقالته ليست نهايه المطاف لكنني تنياهو
الضره الى توقيع كتاب قالته من منصبه
وزيرا في الحكومه عملا بقرار القضاء لتدخل
الاقاله حيز التنفيذ الثلاثاء المقبل
ويدرس نتنياهو ان كان ابقاء درعي في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه المصغره بصفه مراقب
وتصب لاغاله الزيت على نار المواجهه
القائمه على خلفيه محاوله الحكومه اضعاف
النظام القضائي ويخضعه لقرارات السياسيه
ان يصبح الفصل بين السلطات شعارا لا ينفذ
سيجعل جهاز القضائي راضي يخلي الوزاراته
وسياسه الحكومه بدون قدره على منع وقف
خطواتنا تمسح حقوق المواطنه وبعضها يتعلق
بمواضيع امنيه ايضا الى جانب ازمه درع
بدات تصدعات في تلاقي في الحكوميه حيث
قاطعوا وزراء الصهيونيه الدينيه برئاسه
مودريتش جلسه الحكومه احتجاجا على تفكيك
باراستيطانيه فور اقامتها من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
واكتشاف مودريتش ان الجيش لا ينصع لامره
بعدم التنفيذ رغم انه وزير في وزاره
الدفاع فيما طالب الوزير المتطرف من كبير
بهدم تجمع الخان الاحمر الفلسطيني في اسرع
وقت
لن يكون هناك قانون للعرب وقانون لليهود
وعندما يطبق القانون يجب ان يطبق على
الخان الاحمر وعشرات البؤر التي اقامها
العرب القانون هو القانون ولن تكون فيه
تفرقه نتنياه يجتهد في محاوله تهدئه
المخاوف الامريكيين واقناعهم بانه يسيطر
على زمام الامور ولا يترك ذلك لوزاره
المتطرفين لكن ذلك قد يجعل اتمام حكومته
ولايتها القانونيه الكامله موضع شكين حيث
يصطدم بشركائه الطبيعيين ان اراد ارضاء
الاميركيين او اخرين زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اطلس البديل
الامثل للمهمات الصعبه روبوت يغير مفاهيم
الحركه وتحقيق الاهداف
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد نتبع من الصومال حيث
اكد مصدر امني صومالي للعربيه ان القوات
النظاميه هجوم حركه الشباب على مبنى بلديه
مقديشوره وقال المصدر الامني انه تم قتله
ثلاثه من المهاجمين فيما فجر ثلاثه اخرون
انفسهم كانوا يتحسنون داخل المبدا كما ادى
تبادل اطلاق الرصاص بين قوات الصوماليه
وعناصر حركه الشباب الى مقتل عدد من
المدنيه
دعا رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه من
البرلمان فتحي باشا في ليبيا دع الدول
العربيه لدعم وحده بلاده والمصالحه بين
ليبيين ودعم التسويه الليبيه الليبيه لا
يوجد سلطه المنتخب تمثل اراده الشعب كما
توجه بشاره بالشكر للدول التي لم تشارك في
الاجتماع التشاوري لوزاره الخارجيه العرب
في طرابلس
[موسيقى]
هكذا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في تركيا
ستجرى في الرابعه عشر من مايو المقبل يذكر
ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه في تركيا كان من
المقرر لتنظيمها في الثامن عشر من يونيو
انظر
الى جنب معكم ايها الشباب لاول مره في
الانتخابات التي ستجرى في الرابع عشر من
مايو كرئيس للبلاد ساستخدم سلطه وستكون
هناك مده 60 يوما ستسيرها هيئه انتخابات
عليا
[موسيقى]
لا تزال الصين تحت تاثير اسوء موجه كورونا
في اخر الاحصائيات اعلنت السلطات وفاه
اكثر من
12.600 شخص بسبب الفيروس الاسبوع الماضي
اي قبل الاحتفالات بالعام القمريه الجديد
بينما سجلت الصين نحو الستين الف حاله
وفاه مرتبطه بكرونا ما بين الثامن من
ديسمبر الماضي حتى الثاني عشر من يناير
الرجال لكن بعض الخبراء رجحوا ان يكون هذا
العدد اقل بشكل كبير عن الحصيله الفعليه
الكامله لانه يستبعد اولئك الذين
[موسيقى]
فيديو جديد نشرته وشركه التقنيه الامريكيه
الروبوت اطلس وهو يقوم باعمال مبهره
مستخدما يديه بطريقه ديناميكيه الروبوت
يلتقط الاشياء من على الارض وينقلها من
مكان لاخر وفي الوقت ذاته يقفز بحركات
بهلوانيه شهيد
[موسيقى]
واو مبهر حقا هذا الروبوت اطلس وبهذه هي
المشاهد مشاهدينا ناتي الى ختام اخبار
الساعه تفكيرهم بابر زهره
حول
انتقام الروسي
بعد خيبه املها في الحصول على الدبابات
اوكرانيا تعزيز جيشها وتحول مدينه اشباح
لقاعده تدريب المكثف
ايران توسع حمله التهديداتها ضد اوروبا
قوائم ارهاب مماثله واستهدفه مصالح في
اسيا وخطه عاجله للرد
في غرفه المعيشه التخزين والمكتب لعنه
الوثائق السريه تلاحق بايضا ومداهمه وشيكه
لمنزله الثاني
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى على العربيه دوت نت وعلى صفحتنا على
مواقع التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]